this is a production of cornell
university
off you go
thank you jen look
very warm introductions
first it's it's a really a pleasure to
be invited to the cornell plan planned
reading seminar um i think this is my
second one the first one maybe was in
2017. i don't know whether it was
the
this formal seminar it was a different
forum but i remember uh being there and
giving a talk
so
a lot of things have happened since then
uh so i am based in ibadan at the
international institute of tropical
agriculture that's
the abbreviations i ate here
i started
my career
as a postdoc
in 2009
two years in nairobi and then
a little bit later i moved to ibadan and
that's when next year was just starting
and i i recall
very well meeting with jean-luc and
everybody else in san diego trying to
craft together uh what would um the
investment of of modern cassava breeding
look like
and so today i'm going to give you a
brief update
um this work
that i would present
is has been contributed to by a lot of
people
uh
mainly from from iit of course but also
from cornell uh not forgetting the boys
thompson institute team our national
partners uh in nigeria in uganda and
tanzania uh ambrapa in in brazil and
seattle colombia but today i will only
focus mostly on um the iita cassava
breeding and specifically the west
africa where i'm based
so
um
i'm sure after a decade of uh
working with iit and many folks in
cornell know about cassava but maybe for
those who don't just a couple of slides
on on why this crop is very important um
you know it feeds a
almost more than half a billion people
in the tropics
it's the most if not if not um um if
it's one of the most if not the most
drought tolerant uh staple crops out
there and it's
considered as a food security crop in
many countries because it doesn't have
like a specific harvesting time you can
leave it in the ground until when you
need it and you just harvest as as you
want to consume
um
and nigeria is the leading producer in
the world
uh followed by other countries in africa
like dr congo
and i'm just showing the other other
regions like brazil where cassava
originated from
thailand in asia where it's a big crop
also
and seat in colombia where our assist
organization is working on the same crop
in terms of
hectares of course nigeria is is leading
uh but in terms of productivity the the
yields have stagnated uh for the last
few decades and so we hope that with the
new varieties that we are launching in
the country uh we should be able to
break through that beginned um ceiling
so iitf was cassava program was founded
in the 1970
and
since that time the early breeders of
course what they do is they start by
assembling the geoplasm most of it
came from east africa which had an
earlier breeding during the cut the
german colonial time in tanzania so some
of the jumpers were gotten from there we
we also received a lot of seats from
brazil
um
representing the latin american
and then west african lion braces and
basically the bleeding was following the
classical phenotype-based recurrent
selection uh where you know control
process even at that time the breeder
started with controlled crosses between
different parents
uh trying to combine different traits
and uh the flow was um you know
it took several years before variety is
identified because cassava is an annual
crop so
every stage of evaluation
takes
a year
and
of course they did recycling but the
recycling sometimes was just like
pedigree based uh they know of a parent
that has a good characteristics and
i'm not sure whether it was like
they were using the formal like uh
uh
recurrent selection uh approach but
anyway any genotype that was used as a
parent usually had like several years of
data so long breeding cycle
uh so the the our program is
decentralized so we have i'm based in
west africa but we have programs in east
africa uh central africa and south and
africa
uh this this the west africa is the
largest
and over the years we have released more
than 40 improved uh varieties and
somebody can get them from this link
here
so a brief history or the evolution of
the of the breeding
targets over time
of course being an introduced crop
because i've encountered like had a
hostile encounter with pests and
pathogens that were not occurring in the
center of origin of the crop
particularly the viruses like cassava
mosaic cassava brown streak
and so on
of course also at that time people are
very conscious about cyanide poisoning
that can come from consuming cassava
varieties that have high cyanide
potential
so the early breeders what they did was
really focused on
tolerance or resistance to these
viruses and
low cyanide content
and as time went by uh once once they
started fixing those trades
then the focus shifted to yield
um early maturity drought tolerance in
the 1990s and then bio-fortification
came
in the 2000s and then during the next
gen era uh of course we we started
focusing more on dry matter content and
quality traits in addition to all the
other traits that that had been quantum
and this is the time that really
molecular breeding or genomic selection
took off
the use of more you know formalized
quantitative genetics principles like
selection indexes
uh mixed models use of blobs
to to make advancements rather than just
finite
observations
so
these are the some of the historical
trends that um was reported back in the
day for example cassava mosaic disease
there was a
decline in the
susceptibility so so genetic progress
there
of course for yield another target trait
there was also progress but for dry
matter it was almost like
zero progress
at that time
so
but one good thing that happened is that
the
iit breeders actually
had a collection they called genetic
gain so this genetic gain collection is
every line that reaches uniform yield
trial they are put in in this
collection uh it's continuously
evaluated the data is recorded and the
materials were existing in the field and
this happened to be the foundation of
the iita genomic selection
uh when
when the gates foundation um did a quick
or ask for a quick um proof of concept
sort of like analysis uh that's when we
reached to
we reached out to
the field got some leaf samples genotype
them and that that
kicked off the the project and and these
are the
collections
that we still have here
of course um
so what did we do during that first
decade or the first five years of of
breeding um we try to solve the crop
specific bottlenecks so long breeding
cycles uh solving the problem of
flowering of seed seed sets
and so on
and
in the
later phases and up to now we're also
focusing more on the structural
bottlenecks that is uh
really going to the foundation of of
breeding uh optimizing every part of the
pipeline
uh
of course
manual data collection um
breeding databases and all that so all
these were the problems that mexican
helped us to solve and all that was
geared to optimize the breeders
equation as you can see here
um so
i don't need to reiterate this but these
are the partners that we have worked
with over the years starting from the
cornell team in the u.s
various partners in africa and some in
europe and latin america and so on
so
what did we do
the first thing that we did was to
tackle the problem of long breathing
cycle so instead of recycling patterns
after four or five or six years
we
ran
basically genomic predictions with the
help of jean-luc's team
and we were able to demonstrate that you
could actually recycle on an annual
basis
basically
using the training population that we
had built over time
we could make new crosses
and at the seedlings they select
whatever number that we have the
capacity to genotype and predict their
uh performances
and put them back in the crossing block
um and this is how it worked so
you know it's an annual crop but if you
plan it very well you can plant the
crossing block
uh at the right time make sure you
harvest the seeds
in december for example in nigeria here
and within a short period of time we
were able for example to transplant
those seeds extract dna and get the
genomic predictions and then
come next june put them back in the
crossing block
and and this is just some evidence of
you know one season and one cycle of
recombination
uh
or sibling necessary all the way from
germination transplanting to cloning
back to the crossing level
how did the predictions uh how are the
predictions performing
this is just one of this one results
from a particular cohort
for some traits the accuracy is good
you know for example dry matter content
here or disease resistance but for other
traits especially like the ones that we
really care about um like yield
sometimes it can be as low as
0.10.2
but you know it depends on the
population like if you if you if you're
using the current cohorts if you're
predicting the new cohort and your
training population is two generations
back sometimes the accuracy
drops off significantly
um
that notwithstanding i think um
there was some
innovations or improvements in our
genomic selection so instead of
predicting individual traits we
thought how maybe we can start
considering predicting uh cross means so
family based
or made selection approach
um so
of course this work was also implemented
together with the
cornell team manning wolff was like the
spearhead
in this activity
and we're happy to report that we're
actually um
using that right now in our crossing
block so we can say okay we want to
predict we want um
[Music]
which set of patterns can we cross
to get for example a certain product
profile with the certain level of dry
matter and so on and so forth and these
are the accuracy of predicting the
families crosses
and you can see they're much higher
than
they were for example for the
individual performance predictions
and even better
this is still being tested but we can
actually target crosses that we didn't
make
before
and uh attempt those process because the
predictions
indicate maybe they would have had
better performances
as you can see here
so
another thing that we have been doing
recently is you know
there are some key performance
indicators that that the the breeding
program is being judged on one of them
is the rate of genetic gain so it's no
longer sufficient
for a breeder just to report that oh i
have released this number of varieties
the donors partners are interested to
know how good
are the materials that you're bringing
out and one of the the the approaches is
to to measure rate of genetic gain of
course if you have checks that are
connecting your different uh
trials uh you can easily um
calculate the rate of genetic gain by
just regressing uh the genotype mean
with the year of origin and in this case
we see that
the pre-next gen
error
and this this
this this
the values here are based on the total
genetic
merit which is which is a composite
index
that uh encompasses the trace that we
have been selecting for like yield dry
matter content disease resistance and so
on so based on on this overall merit you
can see that there was the progress has
been slow in the historical times but uh
during the next-gen era the slope
is is much
steeper
and
we um released the first set of
varieties that were developed through
genomic selection
i think in the whole cg maybe this was
the first
report of that
and
we have
four out of the five varieties that were
released in 2020 were the products of of
um
gs
now
moving on to the other improvements
which is digitization um
the shelf that you're seeing on this on
this picture on the left is actually the
the real original field books that was
used by breeders in 1970s you can go
back to those records and find out okay
they have like the pedigrees and the
phenotype data that was recorded
but
during next-gen
we changed uh together with the lucas
mueller's lab
we adopted cassava base and this has
really revolutionized our
breeding data collection and management
and phenotyping
a lot
so
it's become almost like a second nature
to us just to
carry our tablets to the field
everything is pre-loaded and go and
capture your data and submit it in green
time and it is by far the largest user
of the the cassava base system we have
not only
uploaded our recent trials but we have
uploaded everything all the way back to
the 1970s
and
anyone in the world with the access to
internet can go there and and download
some of the data
so not only the phenotype data but the
genotype data as well and implode images
which is another very interesting
functionality and and we can do
basically almost everything that we need
in terms of the data management uh
on this ecosystem
flowering is the other challenge of
course i think a team is there team has
really helped our program
so
some of our
majority of our genotypes they can
flower but there are some that are
recalcitrant and
we
we needed a way
that we could tap into the alleles that
they have and so through the experiments
and innovations from his team we were
able to come up with a protocol that
almost we can say we can we can induce
flowering on demand
um we have you know phd students that uh
also graduated from that lab
uh developed helped to develop some of
this this method so
then
another thing is we did is um genetic
architecture of the traits that we're
interested in of course when you're
doing genomic selection obviously you're
generating a lot of phenotype and
genotype data and so out of curiosity
but also like
going after the low hanging fruit we
also um have been intensively working on
mapping
genes or major qtls uh for simple traits
that that we can use
a few markers without necessarily going
for gs
um so
using a large collection of like three
cycles of genomic uh recurrent selection
populations uh we were able to welcome
about 14 traits
and many of those traits we were able to
map them at very high high resolution i
can see the minus log p values some of
them going up to
you know 100 plus
here so very very precise
and
this is just an example of the cassava
mosaic locus this this locker cmd2 on
chromosome 12 is already well known
but although the new ones on chromosome
14 we were able to actually
identify them
because of the power of the large
population that we had and this is a
serious virus disease that
is important economically for for
cassava production
but we didn't just stop there but we
also
went ahead and said okay we want to val
convert this gbs
markers into assays that can be deployed
and used
by any program or anyone in the world so
we followed standard
marker conversion and validation where
we did
assay development breeding validation
technical validation
biological validation whether it has
good
predictions and so on and then
deployments so these are just some of
the markers you can see there the
scoring is very clear
and some of the traits for example for
mosaic disease the prediction you know
because it's a monogenic sort of trait
we can identify resistance and
susceptibles quite well but of course
there are some of those
misclassifications that that happen
yeah
but we are not satisfied with that of
course to succeed you have to
have the culture of continuous
improvement
continuing to work with the cornell team
but also with the excellence in breeding
that is at the cg level
we went back and said okay now we have
we have overcome some of the challenges
that that cassava breeders historically
have been facing now how do we bring
these tools back
and um
maximize
the return on investment in terms of
rate of genetic gain so we revisited
starting from the foundation uh looking
at
do we really have a good breeding
targets
or are we just focusing on traits like
you know in the historical days breeder
would just say okay i want to just work
on this particular trade because i think
it's important but do we have the market
intelligence to tell us what are the
product profiles that we should use
what is our grading scheme uh well
optimized are our trials um
sufficient and so on uh what kind of
selection methods are we using
um
and
and other things so we went to do to
look at this and we said okay we can do
different kinds of modernization one is
structural so at the programmatic level
and the second one is optimization
of the breeders equation so just to
increase the selection efficiencies
so one of the first things we did was to
better define breeding targets with the
work that we did with the harley 2 funds
group
on market surveys and so on we were able
to identify what are the different
market segments that that we should be
focusing on
and after that
we also
came up with the formal definition of a
product profile so product profile say
this is an example of cassava for
industry industry means like cassava
that is mechanically planted
mechanically harvested for their roots
to convert them into starch or flour
what kind of trays do we need so we can
group the trades here whether it's yield
agronomic trades disease resistance
rates and so on and so forth and then
define whether these trades are
essential or nice to have whether the
trades are
for improving or just maintaining at a
certain threshold and then the minimum
scores and the way of scoring them has
been clearly different
we also
have been recently developing a formal
um
breeding stage gate system so
maybe this is the way
companies operate
and
of for private breeding companies
operate so everything is
well demarcated and there's clear
criteria from moving from one stage to
the other so product design is the first
stage which is um
based on the the market intelligence and
so on then trade do we have the trades
then trade discovery trade deployments
so these are pre-breeding based uh faces
and then the actual breeding which is my
my area is from here crossing testing
method testing and
release
and
for each place we have sort of like a
criteria we have a dimension so we know
how many lines does our program have the
capacity to carry and advance from one
stage to another one uh
what kind of
[Music]
protocol or sop do we need to follow to
move materials from one place to another
one another area that we worked on is
the optimization to to
on the breeders equation so looking at
the evaluations our selections
are crosses
and here i'll just look at one
on the evaluation so in terms of
evaluation uh
you know when we inherited the breeding
program
we had a certain number of locations
that breeders were just using but we we
didn't know for example
uh how
accurate how useful are these locations
how correlated are these locations do we
need all of them can we do with uh do we
need more do we need less and so on and
based on for so if you take a complex
trait like yield
that has low heritability uh high g by a
then we need to to to look at our
environments and look at
how are the genetic correlations between
the environments you can have a
situation that is really bad where it
can be from negative to positive one
um high g by e to positive correlate
positively correlated environments and
so if you select materials from one
environment
you expect that the same set of lines
would be performing equally well in the
other environments
so
this is the map of nigeria
based on the first few years of
materials we
run trials from the north to the south
of the country of course we are based in
the in the
in the west here uh so most of our
trials here but we we made the effort to
to plant them in in many of those other
locations
and so this is an example of
the genetic correlation of environments
for yield
this is the work of moshoot who is
our students with cornell as well uh
almost graduating
and we see for example for yield where
the environment's actually well
correlated um well
except some that have negative uh
relationship with with the others so
what mushu did
was to use for example um classical g by
e analysis but also mixed model g by
analysis factor analytic and cluster
those environments and with the
clustering actually produced very good
results so we know
of course this is as as by the
expectation that the northern regions uh
they are behaving very differently uh
from the southern regions
and so this that gradient has been
confirmed but most important is
how many num how many testing locations
do we need
to capture the totality of the target
population of environment that we are
targeting and in this case depending on
the trades so trade like dry matter with
relatively
stable um or low g by e high
heritability uh we when you go to just
maybe a few locations you're able to to
max on the accuracy but for yield um
the the
the curve is much slower and therefore
you need more environments but i think
we can say okay let's work with
five environments and we get 85 percent
of the accuracy and that that's enough
for us
another thing that we have been focusing
on is quality
because you can just focus on yield
we have situations where you release an
improved variety but
eventually the farmers or the the
consumers reject them the farmers can
sell the products and then
um
it's it's not useful
so
we've been processing the roots into the
various cassava products in this case
it's um
uh gary and fufu for food is like flour
gary is like um
semolina
it's a granulated product
and then
we can do consumer testing
and identify which
which um traits which varieties are
acceptable and which traits are driving
those acceptability
but doing manual testing is is um
is clumsy it's subjective and so on so
we have invested in uh
using instruments especially for the
traits that we're interested in that are
textural are using instrument to
quantify those um measurements
so this is something that is just
started but it's starting to to pay off
because we know that we can get some
accuracy so as a breeder you're
interested in
other states heritable
um
[Music]
do they have g by e
uh what what is the available genetic
variation for this trade so we've
started to address some of those traits
so this is data from one collection over
two years
and we can group the trace into color or
functional properties or textural
properties
uh instrumental and and human sensory
and you can see the the instruments
instrumental uh sensor textual
properties actually have better accuracy
than the human sensory
evaluations because of that subjectivity
so
we now know that these traits can
actually be selected for and this
genetic variability for them
um
the future outlook
of course we've made a lot of progress
under next-gen cassava
um
[Music]
we
want to build on that
moving into the future maybe we can try
a different breeding strategy
for example looking at a reciprocal
recurrent selection where we
identify iterative groups
and start doing population improvements
within each group and then making
test crosses to
develop
a hybrid sort of like cassava even
though as a clonally propagated
heterozygous crop every cassava is
actually and can't be considered as a
hybrid but i mean hybrid in the true
sense of of the word
um high throughput phenotyping it's also
another important
objective
and we've started that already but
there's still a long way to go
of course as i mentioned earlier the iit
casa breeding is broad
most of the improvements have happened
in the headquarters which is
in west africa here but we are very keen
to start sharing and deploying this
technologies
to the other hubs for the other
pipelines and of course we
want to continue working not only with
our international partners like cornell
but also expand our collaboration with
the national program so that we can have
more uh impact
on the ground
um
i don't know how many more minutes do i
have
uh
it's one o'clock so i mean we have
we can start asking questions now or i
mean you have at the most you have say
10 minutes right
okay okay
okay thank you so yeah um of course as i
mentioned this is not just my work and
this is just the iata team of course if
i put
everybody next time that we have worked
with i would have many many slides to go
through
we have here the breeders
the data management
social science food science
our young scientists uh
here postdocs um yeah
thank you
i think that's that's one of my last
names
okay then questions for ismael
and
smell uh let me know if you can hear us
otherwise i'll pass the microphone
around i can hear you very well
okay
uh lina
hi uh my question was um
so there's earlier on in your
presentation um
you suggested that dry matter did not
increase with meal
why would that be
did you hear that smell yeah yeah yeah
i think at that time
the the program was was focusing more on
fresh root gain
so
yeah
i bet
fresh yield is just you know cassava has
starch in it in the roots and it has
water content and it can vary so maybe
uh they were sort of like using a
threshold level
if something has a certain threshold it
will pass if not it won't pass but i
think for us we are more interested in
improving that trade so it is now part
of the index
uh i have a question from from the chat
from from walter
walter to young use the potato breeder
here he goes right for the jugular his
question is how much has the breeding
modernization increased adoption of new
cultivars and or
decreased the average age of cassava
cultivars so you know
uh if the replacement of cultivars
happens more quickly than the age of
cultivars is going to go down
um any thoughts as well
yeah
so of course um
i can give a long and convoluted answer
but i'll go straight um the the answer
is that we haven't started seeing the
fruits yet
but i i think we couldn't have been in a
better time
to realize those foods and a lot of
things have aligned
for example for cassava breeding in
africa
one is that
historically varieties were released
and just handed over to release
the release authorities sometimes they
would just put the stems on the shelf
there was no push to to disseminate
those those improved varieties but right
now along with the breeding they are
serious investments in seeds formal seed
systems and one of the things that we're
doing now is we're doing for example
product launch or product demo so every
improved variety that has been
recently released or promising varieties
we are growing them we are bringing um
commercial growers small-scale growers
there's a lot of hype in the media
social media and so on and that is
driving demand so we hope to see some of
the fruits of those efforts soon
other questions
holly oh yes i don't know
how you smile it's holly here i'm
wondering there's some talk around
target population environments including
kind of social variables
have you considered that in your work or
is that in the horizon thank you
yeah
certain so so far we haven't um
[Music]
but i think as we continue to refine our
market segments so market segment is
defined by a group of growers
that have a common um
needs
then of course
social constructs play a role in that
and definitely we will start
if need be we will start focusing on
those areas as well yes but because
right now we've been
you know like yield so yield is cutting
across and so
just from the quantitative genetic
perspective um
how many locations do we need
to select accurately for yield so that's
the first question but as we move into
the other traits that
have
the social aspects to them then
definitely will consider that as well
maybe a related question
does int at the moment have actually
different breeding pipelines for each
market segment or is it more that you
have one overall breeding pipeline
and then as you
as the varieties that look good sort of
are starting to get closer to consumer
release
you kind of decide uh this one is more
appropriate for that segment that one is
more appropriate for the second segment
and you sort of
separate them out kind of after the fact
yeah we're in the middle part of that
spectrum
um sort of like on a on a small scale we
have started dedicating separate
crossing block
or sets of patterns uh for for different
uh
pipelines of course there are some
pipelines that you can't mix so bio
fortified for example and the
non-bio-fortified um
unless you just want to tap some alleles
if
generally like yield or dry matter then
you can
go back and increase the by
fortification later so those are
different pipelines the one for fresh
markets which must have low cyanide and
quick boiling uh sweet tests and so on
that also is a separate pipeline the the
one for industry uh with the right plant
architecture we can extract that from
the main pipeline just by um
yeah but we haven't started um
having a crossing block for that but for
the others we have started
allocating small proportion of resources
to them
cool
um
i have another question just in case but
anyway
oh online
where do you see the greatest need for
higher throughput phenotyping
[Music]
quality quality traits
is is a rich limiting step
a
for example
if you want to assess the product
quality of cassava you you have to
take the rules to a centralized place
process them
and
everything is so labor intensive that we
can only do that at the last stage of
evaluation so maybe at that time we have
lost a lot of the genetic variability
and so if we can have uh
if we are able to do that earlier on say
at this first or second stage of
evaluation
then so much better
of course we have partners like the rtb
foods um team uh working on that but i i
think that's an area that that we need
to work on maybe i have one small slide
here so we're starting to use um
near-infrared uh spectra
spectrophotometry or spectroscopy
to
do some predictions so for some of the
traits it's working very well for
example dry matter starch content but if
it comes to those functional or textural
properties of the food
then
we haven't got a good handle on that
got it this is a nice slide
yes
um
okay so my other question was uh okay
your job title is molecular breeder for
cassava at iita and you showed some
slides that are they were sort of
clearly genetics oriented gewa stuff
like that you showed some other slides
that are very much organizational like
stage gates we've been talking about
market segments
um you know if you were to look back at
yourself if you were to give advice to
yourself from 15 years ago as you're
still in your phd program
and sort of say hey
uh is my younger ismail you ought to
learn something about x
what would x be
for you to be more effective at your job
currently
actually the job title has changed now
in my recent contract review at iit
they changed it to cassava breeder
all right that sounds good
but okay so that doesn't change my quest
yes yes yes yes i agree um
it's a journey and uh
one of the things that is very
fulfilling is actually seeing impacts
on the ground
and of course as you start in your
career your laser focused uh microscopic
sort of like you know somebody can can
you know go flat out on a certain trait
or
a certain
issue
but you know as as
as time goes by you realize that the the
bigger picture
and
then
of course all these other things like
better management skills people
management skills program management
skills and all that really helps to make
sure that um
everything is is is moving along um i
don't know if that answers your question
but
in the beginning i was less focused like
i
any topic i would have taken there for
example
the traits i showed you we started with
classical qtl mapping in cassava we
developed the first genetic linkage map
based on snips we contributed a lot to
the reference genome development um all
the linkage maps that that went into um
anchoring the cassava scuffles and so on
uh we went into
you know
the
wild cassava chromosome segments that we
discovered um occurring in chromosome 1
and chromosome 4 and that you know
became research and gained a life on its
own
um and any any given trait if you want
or this quality traits it's a whole
it can be a whole seminar on its own but
i think for today i was maybe more
trying to focus on on the
like what i would like to see on the
bigger picture level
great i mean in terms of the things that
you said they all involved management i
think
yes
um
any any last questions
i'll go ahead like
hello
so um on the idea of like generating
hybrids would you have to create inbred
lines or i hope you say no way mike
no way
that one would be good
all right good
good yeah very clear yes
uh okay so just i'm going to answer
mike's question a little further um iata
does a lot of cassava breeding there's a
lot of cassava breeding both iit and
seattle are exploring this idea of
reciprocal recurrent selection to
generate
cassava hybrids seatt is interested in
in the whole question of doing a little
bit of inbreeding before they make their
hybrids it looks like iita is just going
to do some reciprocal or current
selection without
inbreeding which in theory can work too
in fact it should work fine
um okay well with that thanks everybody
uh you first year students you're right
on time
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu